It was great to hear Dr Griffiths and Dr Doblin discuss their exciting research
with psychedelics. It really is fascinating. Now, in this section of the
lesson, we discuss drugs of abuse and how they produce their psychoactive
effects. And though we discuss the general classes of drugs, there are many
specific drugs that we didn't get a chance to cover here. So now its times for
you to head over to the instructor notes section and read the additional
material that you'll need for this lesson. There we're going to discuss more
drugs, and we're also going to look at the evaluation process for drugs getting
approved by the FDA. And, finally, we'll finish up with some treatments for
drug dependents, so head on over to the instructor notes section.